[Music]
it's just at Starbucks the other day
studying away and I did something I've
never done before what I usually do when
I want to get in the zone is I set a
timer for about 20 to 40 minutes and
when that timer is done I can take a
break and you know walk around order
another coffee or whatever but this time
what I did is instead of setting a timer
which counts down
I set a stopwatch which counts up so
once I hit start I plug my headphones in
played my sacred Productivity playlist
had my caffeinated beverage coffee right
next to me and I went at it knowing that
that number on the stopwatch continually
counting up represented pure
unadulterated productivity and whenever
I felt like there is the slightest drop
in productivity or is feeling a little
bit tired I press stop on the stopwatch
took out my headphones walked around and
did whatever I took a very intentional
break anyways I got a lot more done in
this study session that I have in any
study session in recent memory but why
initially I thought that setting a
stopwatch instead of a timer was kind of
counterintuitive because you're not
working for any set amount of time it's
not strict so what's stopping me from
taking a break after like two and a half
minutes but surprisingly that's not what
I did and I think it's because a timer
counting up puts the exact opposite
mentality towards productivity that a
timer counting down does because when a
timer is counting down in the back of
your head you can't wait till that
number hits zero because then you can
take a break the thing that you're
looking forward to is the break whereas
when you set a timer counting up that
number represents pure work it
represents your productivity and the
result of that is you kind of want to
set a high score the higher that number
climbs the more work you're getting done
another way of looking at it is that
when you set a timer for like 20 minutes
it's something that you're kind of
forced are required to do you're forced
to be productive whereas when the timer
is counting up it's more like you're
encouraged to be productive and work
seems like a more positive thing so
that's it give it a try by using a
stopwatch instead of a timer you might
find that you have a better attitude
towards studying you're more intentional
about your breaks and you're more
productive in less time
if you liked this video and want to see
me make more be sure to hit that like
button if you like videos like these in
general hit that subscribe button follow
me on Twitter at better ideas TV I also
have Instagram and Facebook to follow
those as well that's all for today thank
you for watching and we'll catch you in
the next video